(audience cheering)
All right, everybody`, It is time for Drew's News,
that daily whiff of that fresh, big, good news pie.
(inhaling) And with me at the desk is my little pumpkin pie,
Rossy Ross Mathew.
That's right.
(audience clapping)
Hi everybody, hi.
Hi Rossy.
Hi Drew.
All right, first, we're gonna jump ahead
to Christmas for a minute.
Ross, do you remember Rockefeller,
the little stowaway owl that they found
in the Rockefeller center Christmas tree last year?
I'll never forget little Rockefeller,
look how cute.
Show off hands who remembers Rockefeller.
Aw, we were obsessed.
Okay, I like, I wanted to know
if almost Rockefeller was single, you know.
(Ross laughing)
Like I wanted to like move in with him
and just live happily ever after.
Yeah, I wish you well.
(all laughing)
I know, it's true, I, huh,
but listen, this is so exciting
because syracuse.com reports that little Rocky
just inspired her own children's book.
It's called the Christmas Owl
and it follows her harrowing journey
from a forest upstate to New York city,
and then to an animal sanctuary,
to her regaining her strength
before she went back home to the wild.
Again, if she moved in with us.
She wouldn't have to.
She wouldn't have to go to the wild.
(audience clapping)
Oh, it's gonna be a best seller.
It's gonna fly off the shelves.
Yeah, (laughing) well, I love her and guess what?
What?
I am gonna purchase a copy and I'm gonna read it
with my two daughters Olive and Frankie and I just wanna,
(audience clapping)
thank that publisher who thought, "You know what?
This is a good idea", I have to say you're right.
All from, well, this is a weird transition,
but from an owl to Turkey day, meat, eat birds.
(audience laughing)
Sorry, let me do it differently.
(all laughing)
Oh, no, it's great, I'm trying to,
date Rockefeller and now you're gonna eat the next animal.
This is perfect.
(audience laughing)
I feel better now, do you want a date or get eaten?
It's your choice.
(all laughing)
Well, Turkey day means the hours and hours
for family conversation, which have you ever been
to dinner during Thanksgiving?
It can get real awkward when the family's around.
You don't want to step in some gravy,
we've got some tips for you.
PureWow, they put together a list of things not,
repeat, not to say on Thanksgiving.
Oh, I can't wait to hear every single one of these.
So give it to me now, Rossy.
Okay, they say, it's gonna be real awkward
if you say things like this, "Hey,
so when are you getting married?"
(Drew laughing)
Don't ask that and I'm planning right now,
so please don't ask me, cause I don't know.
Don't ask me this question either.
"When are you having kids?" or this one, well,
don't ask uncle Larry if he's still
in the closet, don't do that, I don't recommend.
(Drew laughing)
He'll let you know when he's ready.
What about this one?
They say, you're supposed to say, "Oh,
you've really lost weight" or "you've really gained weight."
Don't say that.
(audience laughing)
The other thing to avoid, I think,
don't ask anyone who they're voting for.
That could get real awkward real quick.
It's true, you know, it's funny though,
I'm okay with that kind of chatter.
Like I'm okay with everybody talking
about their differences at the table,
like, why are we pretending we're all the same person?
Okay, that's sweet, I just wanna get it over with.
(audience laughing)
I just, yeah, great cranberry sauce,
aunt Helen, see you next year.
(audience laughing)
Raise of hands who loves their family,
but shenanigans will ensue at Thanksgiving.
I love this.
M-hm, m-hm.
I love it, it's so fun, I mean, I'm telling you,
you could be alone and feeling awkward or you could be
with your family feeling awkward, take your pick.
Yeah, or you could be on a date with an owl.
(audience laughing)
I'm like, Rockefeller.
(all laughing)
We're gonna have you for dinner.
Oh, wow.
Well, next, one of my favorite things
about Thanksgiving is that Turkey day aroma.
It just hangs in the air.
Oh, yeah, oh did you smell it?
And now Southern Living reports
that you can get it without lifting a single pot
with the new Thanksgiving feast candle.
That's right, it smells like buttery, mashed potatoes,
sage stuffing, and cranberry sauce.
Are you ready?
We're gonna take a whiff.
I'm very scared to smell it.
(audience laughing)
M-hm, okay, yeah, m-hm.
I like it.
I like it, it doesn't necessarily smell meaty,
but it smells Thanksgiving-y.
Yeah, it's the more like floral aspect of.
How do you feel about food scented candles
in general?
I'm.
No, no.
Was I asking you?
No, I'm kidding.
Yeah.
(all laughing)
Well like, what if I told you,
cause your food in the world is mac and cheese.
What if I said, oh, they also made a mac
and cheese scented candle, would you be excited?
I would say, "bring me a spoon".
(Ross coughing)
No.
They also make a mac and cheese
(Drew screaming)
scented candle and I have one right here for you my love.
(inhaling) Oh.
(Ross laughing)
It doesn't really smell like macaroni and cheese.
It smells like something.
Oh, God.
This, I think this candle is just perfect.
Next, it's time to review the things
that you want us to in Drew's Reviews.
Okay.
(audience clapping)
Oh, yeah.
And today we're trying a turkey day invention suggested
by Meg Marin via Instagram.
Thank you, Meg, for writing to us.
And you want us to try leftover Thanksgiving nachos.
Okay.
I have to say I've never heard of this.
Has anyone here ever heard of this?
No, but I like all those words in it.
Thanksgiving.
Leftovers, nachos.
All right, let's do this.
Okay, so it's chips with like the turkey.
Yeah, I know, I feel like why am I eating this
with a fork?
The stuffing and the.
Okay, hold on.
And then there's, okay.
(audience laughing)
I didn't realize there was nacho cheese on top of it.
Hey, Meg, Drew can date an owl, I'm gonna date you, okay?
This is phenomenal.
Wow, this is nacho ordinary nacho.
(audience laughing)
Here's my thoughts.
Okay.
I love everything except for the cheese.
Oh, really?
Yeah, because it just, it throws everything off.
The chips with the Thanksgiving flavors are amazing,
but the cheese, I don't know,
it's standing in the way for me.
I feel like I don't even know you anymore.
(audience laughing)
Because the cheese makes it for me.
Oh, really?
Yeah, it takes it to nacho, brings it together, it says,
come on board, we're a nacho now, get into it.
(audience laughing)
Well, Meg, I couldn't have come up with any
of this without you, so I'm gonna give it three
out of five turkeys.
All right, okay.
(audience clapping)
I gotta give it up to you, Meg, for inventiveness.
(upbeat music)